today I'm going to be looking at a
randomly selected deck from one of my
patrons with this one coming from jism
his deck's Commander pairing is erinus
gloomstalker with a background of street
urchin and the first thing I note about
this pairing is that it feels like two
different commanders much more so than
most other background pairings you know
you've got a bunch of these cases where
the background basically acts as an
enhancement of the commander baloth but
big baracos but he draws some extra
cards Wilson but he's a Demon Lord and
so on by contrast street urchin pairs
with aerin's death touch to turn into a
removal engine so the command Zone
effectively ends up offering two
entirely separate things land recursion
and removal let's start by thinking
about the land recursion part the most
simple usage here is using the ability
to ramp with an evolving Wilds type card
or Harrow effects and indeed the deck is
doing a good amount of this it also
contains several different lands with
interesting sacrifice abilities as well
as four artifact lands to fuel street
urchin for the removal part the deck is
running lots of artifacts and creatures
it's okay with sacrificing as well as
cards that generate tokens with these
two things land recursion and removal in
its pocket the deck is looking to
generate advantage in cards and Mana
over the course of the game while
keeping its opponents in check via its
built-in creature removal as well as
removal for artifacts and enchantments
once the board state is under control
and it has built up enough resources the
deck then looks to win either by
swinging in with the board of big
creatures or by playing a buffet
equipment and hitting its blocker
opponents with aoness a few times having
laid out my understanding of what the
deck is trying to do my next question is
how is the deck doing at accomplishing
its goals first of all the removal
engine in the command zone is pretty
fearsome at any point in time you can
pay one and sacrifice an artifact or
creature to kill an opposing creature
the deck packs 19 total cards that
generate creature or artifact tokens and
11 other artifacts and creatures that
the deck is either indifferent about
sacrificing or actively wants to
sacrifice I want to highlight a couple
sack fodder cards I find particularly
neat Canan of Calamity is a nice
creature with Myriad and the tokens it
creates can either be sacrificed in
response to their damage triggers when
they've already gotten all of their
value or before blockers are declared so
the deck can clear a path for aess to
dish out some Commander damage another
fun one is humble Defector activate
sacrifice and response get them guards
finally treasure vault is a cool option
for resource building it can be
sacrificed on an opponent's endstep and
brought back each combat allowing the
deck to accumulate mana and sacrifice
artifacts if the game is in a lull and
it doesn't have quite what it needs to
win yet overall the suite of sacrifice
bles that the deck has seems more than
adequate the number of ways to get lands
into the graveyard is also pretty solid
eight slow fetches seven other sack
lands 10 disc artifacts four artifact
lands that can get sacrificed to street
urchin three Harrow effects and a few
other cards this this deck also runs
quite a lot of draw overall including a
whole bunch of filtering some more
generic choices and a handful of things
such as Keen sense that pair nicely with
the commander this draw paired with the
deck's healthy Suites of cards
supporting its command Zone lead to the
deck being able to jump into its land
recursion and removal based game plan
with a high degree of consistency the
next ramp Suite is particularly
interesting to me in the sense that the
only ramp card in the deck that isn't
specifically supporting the command zone
is soul ring the deck could run dorks to
boost out ainus a turn earlier or rocks
to boost the deck's overall Mana count
going into the mid game but these
options would eat up slots that could go
to making sure the deck has lands in
yard and stuff to sacrifice on board the
result of this choice is that the deck
operates with a very consistent curve
ainus played on turn three street urchin
presumably played turn two or turn four
and whatever the utility plays needed to
set up the deck's engines on other turns
with aoness ramping a land on the combat
step of turn turn four as far as winning
the game goes the deck has a few buff
equipments that can let the commander
kill opponents in two to three hits a
few big landfall creatures and a handful
of other sizable creatures on the
surface this doesn't seem like very much
can this selection of stuff really win
the game well I haven't played games
with the deck myself so I obviously
don't know for 100% sure but it follows
a principle I laid out in my wicon video
which is that control decks can win
games with less powerful finishers than
mid-range decks simply because they
generally have more time to work with
and less onboard resistance to worry
about once gr control gets the game into
a soft lock where major opposing threats
are all under control hitting opponents
three times each with an adventuring
aoness is a win plan I could absolutely
see being viable playing more powerful
cards to win is certainly an option but
I could totally see an argument that if
the deck doesn't need them why play them
another area of the deck I can comment
on is the Mana base and with 21 Green
symbols and 18 red symbols within the
the lands I'd call the Mana base not
amazing but passable and it's certainly
somewhat helped by the deck having nine
instances of lowcost filtering available
single red as well as land recursion in
the command zone for single green
finally I like that the deck contains
several protection spells since it's so
reliant on the command Zone and I think
this problem is also somewhat helped by
aon's Cheap cost and built-in ramp which
make needing to replay him once or twice
not a super big deal the reactive part
of the command Zone package the removal
is also usable anytime both ainus and
street urchin are in play meaning that
opponents will struggle to keep this
removal engine offline for long unless
they're willing to throw a lot of pieces
of removal at the commander aoness is
still naturally going to be a weak point
due to the deck being heavily built
around him being in play but due to the
factors I mentioned I don't think it's a
crippling problem or
anything okay I've gone through stuff
that I think the deck either does well
or does acceptably at if I had to sum up
the biggest issue I see with this deck
it's actually mostly a social one this
is a decidedly midow deck in terms of
its speed and how it wins the game but
for a midow deck it's brutally effective
at killing creatures and there will
naturally be players at that power who
aren't thrilled to have their board kept
empty of meaningful threats the whole
game so why not make the deck more
powerful to have it play at a level with
more tuned Cutthroat decks the issue is
that there are several factors about
this deck that make increasing the power
level difficult and to demonstrate this
I'm going to explore a few different
potential Improvement routes for the
deck and talk about where I think they
fall short for one what if we increase
the speed of the deck add some one man
ad dorks or replace some evolving Wilds
type cards with actual fetchlands as I
mentioned earlier the issue with adding
faster ramp is that the deck's choice
not to run ramp that doesn't support the
command zone is part of what lets it
jump into its core game plan with such a
high degree of consistency if you start
replacing Harrow effects and treasure
generators with ramp that lets you get
out aoness on turn two you'll get aoness
triggers earlier but you'll have on
average fewer lands in the graveyard and
fewer tokens to sacrifice negating some
of that increase in speed I think
ultimately efforts to improve the Deck
ramp Suite would end up being a wash
giving it occasionally more explosive
games at the cost of doing what it wants
to do less
consistently actual fetchlands on the
other hand would likely make the deck
faster but they alone won't make the
deck that much better and are also
pretty pricey another Improvement Route
would be adding more protection since
the deck relies heavily on its command
Zone and thus has a pretty big point of
failure and I wouldn't mind a couple
more protective cards but this is once
again a bit tricky due to the deck
wanting to have as many slots as
possible devoted to making sure its
command zone is able to do what it wants
to do additional protection comes at the
cost of the speed and the consistency of
the core game plan the deck's colors are
another challenge a lack of white or
blue means the deck will struggle to
deal with certain types of removal and
this color pairing additionally limits
the amount of Stack interaction the deck
is able to run to prevent opposing winds
destroying some creatures and artifacts
might be able to slow down opposing
decks but this is the sort of deck that
will really struggle to contain more
explosive winds if it ever falls behind
making Decks that win with Combos and
non-creature means a tricky matchup this
brings me to a third possible way to
improve the deck improving its finisher
Suite one option for doing this could
consist of adding a couple gnarlier
landfall creatures such as scoot swarm
or morog and another option would be
adding an infinite combo of some sort
but both of these approaches have
problems adding more powerful landfall
cards won't improve the deck's power
level that much as these are still
threats that require some time and set
up to win and the plan of adding a combo
to our control deck to help it win
before an opponent plays a threat it
can't deal with kind of conflicts with
its identity as a control deck right
obviously this is subjective but in my
book this deck's G game plan should be
to out grind not outrun generating
resources and stabilizing the board
State should be your focus not rushing
to find combo pieces overall there are
ways for the deck to bump up its power
level a bit but the most concrete one
starts with buying or proxying
approximately $180 worth of lands for a
two-color deck itself a move that feels
strange and further upgrading attempts
might risk fundamentally changing the
identity of a deck in a way that is less
satisfying overall I don't think it's
worth it to make major changes to this
deck and even the handful of additions
and cuts I would make are subjective
choices and still maintain the middling
power level of this deck the deck's
conundrum where upgrading is hard but
playing at Mid power can feel weird is
one I find familiar it reminds me of a
scrapped deck idea I featured in a
pretty early video on this channel a
child of Alara Maes end deck will likely
perform decently at a midrangey mid
power table but it's a deck that will
fall on its face in a handful of
matchups while creating a miserable
table experience in all the other ones
I'm not going to elaborate too much on
that concept here but I threw a link in
the description if you want to hear my
full thoughts on the subject of running
a heavy duty removal suite at a middling
power level though the principle is the
same Grill control is certainly less
severe than that child of Lara deck due
to its removal being single Target
creature removal rather than non-land
permanent wipes and I actually think
that fact gives it a valid position at a
lot of midow tables
as long as people know what the deck is
capable of and to expect their creatures
to get yeed it can play into a flexible
Archen enemy Dynamic where the table
tries to figure out how much resources
to spend suppressing it while also
keeping in mind that fully locking it
out removes a roadblock for their
opponents to win with a creature-based
windc con this can lead to some really
cool gameplay my gissa deck generally
tends to play into a similar Dynamic but
it's important to make sure that the
table is into that sort of gameplay it's
also a type of deck that should be
played sparingly in my opinion it can be
fun to occasionally pull out a deck that
demands the table's full attention
especially if the table is full of
Solitaire mid-range but pulling out that
type of deck too often can lead to other
people feeling like a side character in
the four-player game they're playing
this is the sort of deck that's fun to
think and talk about to me because it
serves as an interesting case study into
the ways that people relate to games
they play and what people find fun
that's all I have to say about the deck
but you can check out joov ism's deck in
the description and let me know if you
think my analysis is correct or if you
have a different way you'd go with the
deck also make sure to do all the
interactive things liking and
subscribing and all that jazz I also
want to give a shout out to my patrons
both in general for giving me money and
for submitting decks for the strong this
was a lot of fun and I look forward to
doing more of these in the future all
right bye now